[Music]
while i was in hiroshima japan
i met craftsmen who embodied the
japanese tradition of takumi
takumi means in japanese a master
craftsman
but it is so much more than that it's
not just a job
it's a passion it's a total dedication
to a single skill
that's an inspiring thing to witness
at mazda it takes years to hone the
skills to become a takumi
at national geographic to become a
photographer like a takumi takes
years and years of dedication and honing
your craft to be a
great visual storyteller it's about
putting all your creative energy into
your work
and that energy being transferred to and
felt by whomever experiences that work
hi we're looking for you to capture the
effort
the energy all right let's do this
we want to see the spirit of the artist
in these photos
i think there's no better way to
challenge our photographers than to have
them capture other people who are
mastering their own craft
no matter what it is yeah that's really
cool and i just can't wait to see what
these young photographers
have in them